[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
c'era una volta una giornalista inglese
che venne in italia
elisabetta era bella e attraente e
aggancio subito il più tipico partito
della nazione come fai a costruire un
soffitto senza innalzare del vinicio 41
anni disoccupato
rientri da 15 anni il vuoto delle sue
giornate giocando alla playstation per
un ammontare di 20 euro di paghetta la
settimana e una quarantina di ore
giornaliere passate a insultare
minorenni dall'altra parte lo schermo
elizabeth e vinicio si conobbero un
pomeriggio in un modo particolarmente
italiano al compleanno di uno che non
era amico di nessuno dei due
insomma ci sono già messi da qualche
parte un paio di giorni che battendo
sulla salaria e fu subito amore
ci siamo visti da qualche parte per due
settimane si coccola ronnie scherzarono
come si fa in italia quando conosce uno
straniero come si dice in italiano
quando dai soldi a camere tipo soldi ma
non si dice ma [ __ ] ordinarono la
pizza a domicilio
ecco credo il resto non è un click qui
ma vaffan luna e fece lo stesso
splendidamente
condividendo i loro segreti più intimi
scusami ma io stramazzare la propria
urla di jalisco
[Musica]
nemmeno io finché un giorno dopo averci
pensato per ore
elizabeth non gli fece la domanda
sbagliata singoli i bambini non lo so
much money oci tanti no in realtà quando
dormo però poi mi ci vedo tutto sudato
almeno un lavoro il lavoro il lavoro i
soldi ci pensa mamma
martedì la chiama per darle una brutta
notizia non ci possiamo vedere ma vivo
salando bene poi ho mandato quanti soldi
ok allora spero che come mia in faccia
giu così domani cinema che magari
tendere sono impegnatissimo li devo
lasciarmi andare a fare la partita di
for the night
poi ti chiamo io dopo due settimane
lo chiama lei disse che stava guardando
i pokémon e che l'avrebbe chiamata il
giorno dopo invece solo più sentito
style mi disse un giorno in un bar
eccola il resto no no no ma in hindi
c'era dirsi cerci cose ha un significato
preciso capito nessuno lo aveva parlato
di quanto fossero [ __ ] gli uomini in
italia l'italia descritta dal mondo come
la culla dell'amore della mafia del
bidet la realtà è che qui nessuno sa
mettere due verbi in croce senza contare
che al posto del bidet la maggior parte
degli italiani preferisce a pulirsi il
culo con i sentimenti degli altri
cupido ha deciso di usare le sue frecce
per farci una colonscopia come siamo
diventati una cosa chiara bile del
pianeta sono a migliaia gli uomini così
a roma forse decine di migliaia le
conosciamo tutti lavorano presso se
stessi fingono di essere sportivi dicono
cose che non pensano anni calli alle
mani per via della solitudine ai quesito
di ogni donna
perché se il mare pieno di pesci quando
vai a pescare bicchi solo scorfani non è
mica vero che siamo tutti messi che dopo
bene anch'io mamma quelle ragazzine
erano la valletta
[Musica]
ho sentito dire sul piano esiste un uomo
ognissanti donne ma che dire poverina
cosa avessero prende gli uomini ormai
abbiamo capito software dicono che se
per fare cose non sanno fare un cazzo
seguono partite non sanno neanche tirare
un calcio al pallone e adesso stanno
sottindere manco scova un giorno sono
più una ragazza su per chiarire la
strafiga sportiva curata per un giorno
mi sono svegliato fuffa terreno
grazie mille già mi sono svegliato e mi
son riscontro esterno il suo tempo vi
darà ei ragazzi devono essere trattate
come delle principesse e loro cercano
solamente un uomo d'accudire come un
figlio per via dello rinato istinto
materno
se gli uomini potessero sfida
penserebbero con le loro madri e con le
madri delle loro madri poveri [ __ ] e
protoni si attraggono per una questione
di chimica cioè voglio dire a me c'è la
prima pensare di essere uno scaldabagno
a pedali ma per cui dovere trattarti
diversamente io ma va in cucina a
scaldarmi the boiler di merda ai le liti
le donne serie non dovrebbero fare gli
uomini dovrebbero fare lo stesso vivere
in un mondo in cui nessuno vuole scopare
lui device che abbiamo in comune noi
ragazzi con le loro madri è che anche
noi non vediamo l'ora di spenderli dalla
nostra ci avete mai sentito due uomini
che parlano di donne è come sentire due
maiali che mangiano mattoni mentre si
notano hanno elevato la stessa merda gli
uomini sono tagli essere costosi e
inutili e privi di cervello non ce
l'abbiamo persona che fa il pendolare
a volte ci abbiamo qui rapporti prendi
il treno e si spostano le mutande
[Musica]
un'altra festa di compleanno in famiglia
un'altra torta fatta dalla mamma è una
canzone di auguri che assomiglia più una
marcia funebre che altro so gia cosa
diranno i mie amici stasera non ha fatto
la festa con gli amici ho capito come
faccio sempre il compleanno con mia
mamma mamma pure nel lato un orologio
prima volta nella storia che torna
dell'antica torino di merda e questo il
motivo per cui qualsiasi donna sulla
faccia del pianeta preferirebbe stare
con un gay piuttosto che con un etero
seminatore rispecchiava il classico che
italiano una [ __ ] senza dignità che
quando parlava di romanticismo elargiva
consigli che puntualmente non riusciva a
seguire vero nel veronese sono un sacco
di donne che non toccherebbe un gay con
un dito tesoro quelle non sono donne
quelle che abbiamo femminucce serie b
secondo me invece le ragazze per paura
della solitudine volte possono fare
delle scelte sbagliate ma ti basi sono
delle principesse le donne sono delle
allupate è che pur di sentire l'odore
del sottopalla sarebbero disposto a
qualsiasi compromesso
no le donne ci preferiscono che tu lo
creda o no perché quando siamo con loro
riusciamo a tirare fuori dei pensieri di
senso compiuto tipo etico che bono
quello tesoro se pazzesca ma secondo te
se glielo su rotoli in mano ci casca
solito e questi li chiami pensieri di
senso compiuto ragazzi ragazzi fidatevi
che sono molto più complessi di quelli
che potrebbe tirar fuori un etero e tu
stai dicendo che praticamente il motivo
per cui le donne hanno smesso di fidarci
e perché non siamo abbastanza green a
chi vanno le ragazze quando si devono
lamentare di qualcuno da noi e quando
invece gli piace qualcuno con chi si
confidano con noi ea chi chiedono il
seme se dovessero tipo rimanere single e
avessero voglia di fare comunque dei
bambini finito era davvero così
per riuscire a conquistare una donna
dovevi veramente comportarti come un gay
che pensiero stuzzicante ai gay
il gay sono la feccia dell'umanità
perché tutti quanti per sono persino
adorabili che siano sensibili in realtà
quelli ciao a tutti la stessa cosa in
testa la stessa che netto non è gianna
di lello non è mica
qualche anno fa si sta per sposare con
un [ __ ] che si chiamava casa
solamente che alla fine lui l'ha mollata
sull'altare così lei ha deciso che per
prima la vongola mamma ma chi le
fidanzate di carla ma a me l'hanno fatta
altre suo padre ma ma la mamma di alice
nodi carli anche quella divisa non ti
muovere state donna ma non ti giravi
però non perda al bar era dimise salta
la mazza una ragazza che mi aveva
spezzato il cuore quando avevo 25 anni e
27 e 30 con denis non poteva proprio
andare
ormai l'avevo capito comunque volevo
fare un piccolo esperimento a parlarci
mi faccio anche la tua di madre
senti come stai io bene tu devi ancora
da tua madre quali trovato qualcosa
piace cercare come si chiamava così però
mi è ancora commento e la grappa ok si
sa i è che da quando mi sono lasciato
con col mio compagno proprio capito di
essere stato un egoista ma hai visto che
è buono che cameriere e tu che sei
pazzesca che stai facendo quasi mai ma
secondo te se glielo solo per in mano
proprio non ci casca sai che che mi
sento così a soli a questo periodo e
l'uva di ripassare un po di coaching
essenziale di misera come la ricordavo
anzi meglio perché tra noi non ci
sarebbe stato nessun pasticcio
sentimentale ci vediamo stasera
improvvisamente non sapevo come uscirne
poi l'idea è che mi manca il mio ex
cosa non ha più una sponda del cuore una
volta che avete sfondato gira
tranquillamente capisco che poi pensavo
fosse un [ __ ] invece è solo un po
confuso 161 io non vorrei che tu
pensassi che magari o tipo abusato di
denti in un momento di debolezza matti
mare
no tranquillo qui davvero anzi se avrai
altri momenti di debolezza
chiamami amiche per la pelle mentre
denise si rivestiva mi resi conto che
c'ero riuscito
avevo appena fatto sesso come un gay me
ne andai da casa di denis sentendomi
incredibilmente potente padroni della
città
niente nessuno potevano fermarmi
primo è molto attraente
secondo non porta alla fede terzo sa che
porto con me una scorta di banana e so
già cosa fare no se così almeno una mela
maggio hai capito c'è n'è una per ogni
buco brutta è meglio che vada a fare a
farvi al lavoro grazie per lo spuntino
e mentre me ne stavo seduto a fissare il
vuoto ea pensare alla donna che aveva
ribattezzato mise big bubble mi resi
conto che forse avrei dovuto inserire un
gps nel casco di banane può di
rintracciarla pensare gare della mamma
ma la partita che ho perso in tv ea cosa
avrebbero fatto i miei amici quella sera
felice avrebbe passato ore attaccando
palle all'albero di natale senna avrebbe
cercato palle tramite tindall e andrea
invece si sarebbe fatto girare le sue
sta operando il profilo della ex mentre
io beh io avrei dovuto trovare un modo
per tornare a casa
e proprio quando credevo che mi sarei
ridotto all'impensabile andare a casa a
piedi
[Musica]
allora che aspetti a salire che cosa fa
esattamente sono uno scrittore che cosa
scrive romanzi nonno scrivo per un sito
che si chiama marmitta i muscoli punto
it ha quindi tra un fallito
diciamo che sto lavorando a una rubrica
nella quale ultimamente parlo di di
donne come conquistare
anzi sì sto lavorando a un articolo che
si chiama con il cuore colpi di verga
spiega quanto sia facile rimorchiare una
ragazza se tvg gay perché perché alle le
ragazze piacciano le battaglie perse e
cosa c'è di male
vedrai un po triste ah ho capito non sei
mai stato innamorato accusa il colpo
in quel momento avrei voluto solamente
tornare a casa e nutre milano cesta di
blatte grazie mille
senti tu sei mai stata innamorata
assolutamente sì
ultima cosa ma dipana lettrice mangiati
tutte assolutamente sì